do it you know you want to
i'll cut you in half come on
right here
don't stop welcome back everyone it's
charlie this is gonna be my video for
the boys season two
episode five there was so much messed up
stuff during this so many easter eggs so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
messed up moment
from the episode on the video so we'll
do top 10 wtf and easter eggs as we go
along there were way extra easter egg so
this video probably a little bit longer
too
careful for spoilers from everything
from the episode
starting with number 10 the dawn of the
seven movie in the joss whedon rewrite
so obviously this is hilarious it was a
very on the nose easter egg about
justice league and batman v
superman the episode starts with them
filming a scene from the dawn of the
seven movie that they've been teasing
all season
it's basically the movie about the
justice league about the seven within
the universe of the boys but they're
parodying the making of the justice
league movie and joss whedon coming on
to do the rewrites for zack snyder after
he was forced to leave the project
they incorporate all this cheesy
dialogue for maeve in this character
named ruby who's a hacker
just the worst dialogue you could
possibly think of so this is obviously
them making fun of joss whedon
and making fun of justice league at the
same time but the whole reason they have
all those scenes with maeve and her
quote unquote lover is because of what
homelander is doing just completely
messing with her just trying to twist
the knife that becomes a really big
subplot later in the episode though
because maeve has her own plan to get
rid of homelander which is really
important for later this season
but while this dawn of the seven movie
shoot stuff is going on it's just
completely hilarious
pj byrne is playing the director you saw
him earlier this season when he was
pitching the movie to them and they were
talking about the script inside vaught's
tower
obviously homelander doesn't care about
the movie he's just there to watch maeve
get
tortured on screen and watch her go
through all this crap but then greg
grunberg shows up in another celebrity
cameo there's all kinds of celebrities
showing up all over the boys season two
we find out that they're riding a train
out of the seven but he tries to rewrite
his dialogue because that's all about
them kicking him off the team so they're
writing that into the movie and he
doesn't want to do that
can we leave it open-ended so pj burn
has to deal with him
i love the fact that he reluctantly
agrees because they basically tell him
that if you don't do this
we're going to fire you and it's going
to be a big scandal but when he's
filming his final scene
it's just a stand-in homelander doesn't
even bother to show up to film the scene
with him because they're filming him
from his back so he doesn't have to be
there
that's another real world thing that
happens all the time when they make big
movies
if you've ever watched the behind the
scenes for a big marvel movie like
avengers end game for instance
benedict cumberbatch was actually
filming other stuff while they were
filming a lot of the big battle scenes
so during some of the big final battle
scenes that they were filming
with all these people running at each
other on screen with this big green
screen behind them
they would have stand-ins for some of
the actors with dots on their faces and
they would just
swap in like benedict cumberbatch's face
or any of the other actors that couldn't
be there at the time because of
scheduling conflicts
another funny easter egg and a big
callback to season one one of the
screenwriters on dawn of the seven
is one of the guys from the therapy
group who got his junk frozen off by the
cold-based superhero
last season they're also part of vots pr
team that wants to turn maeve's
relationship
in real life within the context of the
show into a big pr
event obviously her girlfriend doesn't
want to have anything to do with that
and she's trying to explain to her no
homelander will
kill you if you don't do what he wants
you to do so this is where her plan to
take down homelanders starts which takes
her to the deep so she's going to
manipulate the deep and use him as a
pawn
in her bid whatever her plan winds up
being to get rid of homelander
it's also a bit of a hat tip for her
helping out the boys which is a comic
book thing
eventually in the comics she does the
same thing she wants to turn on the
seven turn on homelander
so you just have one more potential
person inside the seven that's helping
the boys out in addition to starlight
now
the number nine homelander gets caught
on tape with a big collateral damage
situation
the footage of his save is hilarious too
so he flies to a foreign country to take
down a fake
compound v super villain remember
they're also creating the super villains
he was responsible for running this
compound v
all over the world so he himself created
the person that he's there to take down
but while he's doing that while he's
lasering him on the spot in under five
seconds
he accidentally kills another random
person in the village
it turns into a whole big thing and you
see more of the vot pr machine behind
the scenes
please don't say anything until we have
a pr team on this he gets more and more
pissed off at the ceo giancarlo
esposito's character from
blocking him ordering him not to say
anything until they do what they want to
do behind the scenes and get everything
ready
it's just another example of him slowly
feeling like he's losing control like he
thinks he's in control at the beginning
of the season
cut to a couple episodes later and he
has absolutely zero control over the
situation
they used that to get him on team
stormfront like i said at the beginning
of the season alya cash said that
homelander basically hates her character
for the first couple of episodes but she
slowly wins him over and this is the
episode where that happens where he
totally gets on board
with her big social media campaign
machine it was hilarious
watching him try to listen and
understand what she was telling him he
clearly has no idea what's going on with
social media he just loves that it works
so well
and another wtf callback to season one
if you remember
butcher's wife becca was actually hired
by vaude
to be his social media manager in season
one or before the events of season one
and before everything happened with the
superboy and her getting pregnant
but then number eight butcher is
torturing himself after what happened
with becca just gets into a giant fight
it seems like a british
metal bar just letting the crowd beat
him like it's some sort of hellish mosh
pit
he finally makes nice with huey a little
bit and tries to duck the boys so he's
obviously got this plan he's going to
continue to try and get becca back but
it seems like he's really going to throw
himself on some sort of grenade
that comes back around later in the
episode too where he's just like alright
i'm at the end of my rope here i'm just
gonna do everything i can to try and
save my friends
so as bad as butcher got the first
couple of episodes it does seem like
he's coming back from the brink of
darkness at least a little bit
there are a couple funny jokes that they
weave into some of these moments too as
crazy as they are like in the background
you see mother's milk watching an
episode of outlander
and refuses to explain himself to huey
like why are you watching that
the number seven frenchie's trying to
stop kimiko from turning into a true
monster like she was in the comics
so kimiko is actually starting to turn
more into her comic book self she was
way crazier in the comic book
we find out that just like butcher she's
trying to deal with her grief over what
just happened in a really messed up way
but she's turned into a hitman or hit
woman for the albanians because remember
she does have superpowers so she's
actually a really good hit person
frenchie finds out about it when he
follows her and sees that she pulls a
hit on a bunch of russian mobsters who
are all busy arguing about the merits of
the hamilton play i thought that was
kind of funny like they're just
casually arguing about hamilton he's
also horrified to find out that his
ex-girlfriend who he was just with is
the one that's passing along the
information on the hits to kimiko
she'll probably also eventually come
back from the brink like clearly he
wants to help her
and she wants to communicate with him
but he doesn't understand the special
sign language that she created with her
brother so she's not doing real sign
language that's actually a language that
they created
by themselves when they were in a camp a
long time ago as children
i think eventually what'll wind up
happening is that frenchie will learn a
little bit of that he'll start to
understand her
then like her brother said a long time
ago she just stopped talking so she can
actually still
talk she just hasn't talked in a long
time then number six they go to
butcher's aunt in the suburbs and you
learn a lot about his backstory some of
it's really funny some of it's messed up
and they bring terror onto the show from
the comics everybody was wondering if
they were going to do terror
we find out that his aunt is every bit
as messed up as him so it sounds like it
runs in the family
like she seems like this sweet old lady
but then as you learn more and more
about her
she becomes more and more hardcore like
she's a dealer she has a bit of a chem
lab in her basement with prescription
pills
and she swears like a sailor she tells
huey all about butcher's little brother
and how
basically huey looks kind of like him
and is
sort of a surrogate version of his
little brother and in present day on the
boys they have the same sort of
relationship that butcher had with his
little brother
he was his original canary in the coal
mine the person that would bring
butcher back from the brink of darkness
it was just a moment meant to humanize
butcher a little bit more
and bring huey closer to him help him
understand why butcher was so messed up
and why he was so important
inside the boys because remember at the
beginning of the season he's like i
could be the harry potter of the group
i could be the person that nobody thinks
is special but winds up being the most
special boy
so he's starting to realize where he
fits into the boys at least right now
his role could always change in the
future but right now
it's really just balancing out butcher
the number five the boys versus black
noir
there are a couple really funny wtf
moments during
all this and obviously they have a big
standoff with the ceo as well
when huey suggests that they just take
off in the car he can never catch us
mother's milk reminds him no he's faster
than the car so it's just another
superpower that you didn't know that
black noir had we knew he was quick but
we didn't know how quick
butcher actually tries to throw himself
on the grenade and just sacrifice
himself to black noir in order to save
his friends
they blow the hell out of his aunt's
house she doesn't seem to care at all by
the end of the episode she takes it like
a champ
and butcher's only able to save them by
making the ceo
believe that he has evidence against
homelander about his
son and what he did to his wife it's
pretty clear from his conversation with
huey after black noir takes off that he
does not have that evidence like oh yeah
i totally wink wink have it i have
all those pictures that i'll totally
release if they try to hurt us
there's also a big black noir comic book
easter egg here too they've already
changed the character
a lot from the comics but during this
scene here where he's
almost like a finger puppet for the ceo
obeying every one of his commands
that is a big comic book thing it just
lets you know that within the seven
there are people who are more loyal to
vot than others
like homelander is really combative with
the ceo he wants to do what he wants to
do
but black noir seems like he'll do
anything at the drop of a hat that the
ceo says
almost like he's his finger puppet if
they wind up going more down the black
noir comic book path that'll become a
bigger thing later this season maybe
during season three so just remember
that
i love the final scene that butcher has
with terror as well where he replaces
the pig that he humps
with a homeland or doll that's also
right out of the comics the trigger word
that he says to tara to get him to start
humping stuff that's right out of the
comics but in the comics it's way more
messed up because it's actually
happening to real superheroes he tells
terror to start screwing
real superheroes number four wtf the
deep's propaganda commercial for the
cult another celebrity guest cameo by
goran viznich you probably recognized
him at least a little bit i don't know
how big of a character he's going to be
this season
because of this whole storyline with the
church of the collective in the deep
being caught in this cult
obviously the commercial is meant to be
really bad on purpose it's super on the
nose it's just hilarious watching him go
through all these different steps
but remember this is meant to be a
parody of a lot of real world religious
organizations trying to get a toe hold
in hollywood and other major
organizations so they want the deep back
on the seven so that they can have
someone from the church
on the seven and someone they can
control or at least that they think that
they can control
there's also that funny interview with
katie kurick another celebrity guest
cameo where he's talking about his
marriage
obviously this is gonna probably blow up
in the most fantastic way for the deep
but then things slowly start to get more
and more messed up as the episode gets
on so number three wtf homelander goes
to the ante homelander protest
it almost lasers every single person so
obviously this is him just slowly losing
his grip
on reality it just seems like he's going
crazier and crazier which is a bit of a
comic book easter egg
but the big twist here is that he's just
fantasizing about killing
all these people so i did wonder how
they were going to play this because i
didn't think they were going to go off
the rails quite so fast
quite so soon if you've read the comics
obviously we don't want to get too
ahead of ourselves because i don't know
how many seasons of the boys they'll be
before things completely go off the
rails but this kind of gives you a
preview
for what things might look like when
homelander eventually just completely
loses it
right now he's still obsessed with his
popularity and people loving him like he
tells stormfront after her campaign
works i went up five points in the polls
thank you so much i totally owe you
but then number two this is actually a
bit of a teaser for future episodes we
find out that stormfront is talking to
lamplighter who seems like he's in a
psychiatric hospital who's played by
sean ashmore aka
iceman from the x-men movies so
lamplighter is a fire-based hero it's
kind of funny that sean ashbor
ice-based hero is now playing a
fire-based hero what they're implying
is going on here is that stormfront had
something to do
with lamplighter probably winding up in
the psychiatric hospital
and that's probably tied to him being
kicked off the seven before the events
of season one
and killing all those children that
frenchie was actually talking about to
his ex-girlfriend a couple episodes ago
they keep making references to all these
messed up things that lamplighter did
and remember the woman who started the
boys with butcher her grandchildren were
killed by a lamplighter that was the
reason why she started the boys in the
first place
we'll get more lamplighter in future
episodes but this is just a clue to what
stormfront seems like she does
to people that she quote-unquote
controls like she implies when she's
talking to starlight that she's going to
be quote-unquote useful
to her in the future she's going to use
her in some nefarious way or manipulate
her as part of her
terror social media campaigns so it just
becomes clear that stormfront is a
master at manipulating people
this is also a potential future for
homelander too if lamplighter completely
drank her kool-aid and wound up in the
psychiatric hospital what's going to
happen to homelander when she completely
works him over
then obviously number one wtf was
homelander and stormfront going
full gente and there are actually i
think some deeper easter eggs going on
here
too in addition to just the obvious
really crazy stuff that they do together
so he comes to thank her because her
campaign works so well there was a funny
moment too where she's like when it
winds up on your uncle's facebook page
that's when you know that it's working
any sort of laughs kind of nervously
because he has no uncle he doesn't even
have parents that he knows about
that'll be really important in just a
second but clearly they're both
degenerates and she wants something from
him to get her hooks into him
to manipulate him in some way and sort
of use her body to twist him
to her purposes it's not really clear if
she actually has any genuine interest in
him or if she's just using him
but they go full bdsm and you find out
that she's way more powerful than you
thought that she was
she can soak a bunch of his heat damage
from his heat vision like she says see
you can't hurt me very easily and then
they just proceed to have superhero sex
across her entire apartment destroying
the entire place
obviously it's super messed up but the
even more messed up theory here is that
if they're going to stick even closer to
stormfront in the comics talking about
easter eggs
in the comics stormfront was the genetic
template that they used that vaught used
to create homelander
vaude american and vogelbaum may have
used some of stormfront's dna
to help create homelander and make him
powerful because they share a lot of the
same abilities
they're almost the same power level so
stormfront might actually be the closest
thing that homelander has
to a mother and think about it this way
with all the mommy issues that
homelander has
the milk fetish doesn't it seem like
sleeping with his mother accidentally
feels like the most homelander thing you
could possibly do
there's a lot of other stormfront stuff
going on in the episode in the
background too like we find out about
her quote-unquote mother adele
but the thing about her mother like
starlight uses that as the password to
crack her email and finds out all the
emails that she's been sending to that
group that she uses for those social
media campaigns
the adele person in the picture that
she's with is actually a recent picture
and she does look like she could be her
mother in present day but remember
stormfront is 70 years old the woman in
the picture
seems like she's in her 70s so instead
of her mother
she might be lying and this might wind
up being her little sister or something
like that
but post all your homelanders stormfront
theories in the comics
do you think that she's going to
secretly wind up being a version of his
mother
not his traditional mother like didn't
give birth to him but just used a lot of
her dna
to create him so effectively they're
kind of related
it'd be a very game of thrones twist for
the boys in the boys trades in really
messed up stuff like that but my episode
6 video will post next week as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you should see that video when i post it
congratulations ben p
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big boys video please email me on the
about page my channel so i can get your
contact details
everyone click here for that brand new
avengers hulk casting announcement and
click here for the boys season 2 episode
4 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight